This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In December 1968, the crew of NASA's Apollo 8 spacecraft became the first human beings to orbit the moon. The astronauts on board, Frank Borman, James Laval and William Anders had a stunning view of Earth rising over the lunar horizon. Like Christmas Eve, a televised broadcast of the event became the most watched TV program at the time. Oh my god, look at that picture over there.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。1968年12月，美国国家航空航天局（NASA）阿波罗8号飞船的机组人员成为第一批绕月飞行的人类。机上的宇航员弗兰克·博尔曼、詹姆斯·洛威尔和威廉·安德斯看到了地球从月球地平线上升起的壮丽景象。就像平安夜一样，这次事件的电视转播成为了当时收视率最高的电视节目。天哪，看那边的照片。
This is Earth coming up. Wow, that's pretty. Will Amanda's captured the moment in a photograph that came to be known as Earthrise. It showed up planet in a way people had never before seen. A vivid, blue and white orb suspended against the vastness of space. Earthrise wasn't just a beautiful photograph. It became a symbol of the environmental movement and had a profound impact on how people view our planet. Beautiful, but fragile and deserving of our protection. The picture inspired the launch of Earth Day.
这是地球升起来了。哇，真漂亮。威廉·安德斯捕捉到了那一刻，这张照片后来被称为“地出”。它以人们从未见过的方式展示了我们的星球。一个鲜艳的蓝白色球体悬浮在广袤的太空中。“地出”不仅仅是一张美丽的照片。它成为了环保运动的象征，并对人们看待我们星球的方式产生了深远的影响。美丽但脆弱，值得我们保护。这张照片激发了“地球日”的诞生。
It's a global movement that is still around decades later. It involves billions of people around the world. All of this inspired by a simple, beautiful image. This week on Hidden Brain, the power of beauty. Why we are so moved by it, the ways it influences our behaviour, and how our attraction to beauty might unlock the secrets of the universe. In the early 1990s, Anjan Chatejee was a young neuroscientist working at the University of Birmingham in Alabama. On Fridays, Anjan and two colleagues would get together at a local hangout to talk about work in life.
这是一场几十年后依然存在的全球运动。它涉及全球数十亿人。这一切都源于一张简单而美丽的图像。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨美的力量。为什么我们会被它打动，它如何影响我们的行为，以及我们对美的吸引力如何可能解开宇宙的秘密。20世纪90年代初，安詹·查特吉是一位在阿拉巴马州伯明翰大学工作的年轻神经科学家。每周五，安詹和两位同事都会在当地的一个聚会场所聚在一起谈论工作和生活。
And the place we got together was a bar that was close to across the street from where I lived in Birmingham called Garages. And just to set the scene, this is one of these beautiful central courtyards with architectural remnants and wrought iron chairs and magnolia trees, and aesthetically pleasing place to be talking about ideas and talking about life. One evening, as they sat under the magnolia trees sipping their drinks, Anjans friend Britt posed a question. Imagine yourself ten years in the future.
我们聚会的地方是一家酒吧，离我在伯明翰住的地方隔着一条街，叫“车库”。为了交代一下背景，这是一个美丽的中央庭院，有建筑遗迹、锻铁椅子和木兰树，是一个谈论思想和生活的审美愉悦之地。一天晚上，当他们坐在木兰树下喝着饮料时，安詹的朋友布里特提出了一个问题。想象一下十年后的自己。
What would you regret that you hadn't done with respect to your work looking backwards? Brit was fond of asking these meta questions, and it was a nice way because there was also going to be a transition in my life. I was going to move to a new place, new lab, to also generally evaluate how I wanted to direct my attention. Anjhan knew the answer to his friend's question. He wanted to study beauty. He had always been interested in art. As a young boy growing up in India, he spent many hours drawing pictures of landscapes, wondering what made them beautiful.
回顾过去，你会因为没有在工作中做过什么而感到后悔？布里特喜欢问这些元问题，这是一种很好的方式，因为我的生活也将发生转变。我将搬到一个新的地方，进入一个新的实验室，同时也需要全面评估我想要如何引导我的注意力。安詹知道他朋友问题的答案。他想研究美。他一直对艺术很感兴趣。作为一个在印度长大的小男孩，他花了很多时间画风景画，想知道是什么让它们变得美丽。
As a neuroscientist, Anjinn was still interested in that question. He wanted to understand the science of aesthetics. Why are we drawn to beautiful things and how does the mind process beauty? Even more interestingly, what happens in the minds of artists when they produce beautiful works. When I started to look at this in the late 90s, there was virtually nothing written about it from the point of view of neuroscience. There are many ways to study these questions, but one technique is to observe patients
作为一名神经科学家，安詹仍然对这个问题很感兴趣。他想了解美学的科学。为什么我们会被美丽的事物所吸引，大脑又是如何处理美的？更有趣的是，当艺术家创作出美丽的作品时，他们的大脑中发生了什么。当我在90年代末开始研究这个问题时，从神经科学的角度来看，几乎没有任何相关的文献。研究这些问题的方法有很多，但其中一种技术是观察患者。
who have suffered some kind of neurological damage. Anjand began studying artists who had different neurological deficits, like Parkinson's disease, to see what affected her on their art. It was stroke or a brain disorder changes the way people perceive or produce art. It tells you that the affected area was playing a role in aesthetics. In some rare cases, Anjhan says, brain damage seems to enhance people's capacity for art. It's a paradox because on the one hand, you might think that art is the highest expression of our humanity. And yet, with brain damage, we don't ever talk about how someone's language gets better.
那些遭受过某种神经损伤的患者。安詹开始研究患有不同神经功能障碍（如帕金森病）的艺术家，看看这些疾病如何影响他们的艺术创作。中风或脑部疾病改变了人们感知或创作艺术的方式。这告诉你，受影响的区域在美学中发挥了作用。安詹说，在一些罕见的案例中，脑损伤似乎增强了人们的艺术能力。这是一个悖论，因为一方面，你可能会认为艺术是我们人性最高级的表达。然而，对于脑损伤，我们从来不谈论一个人的语言能力是如何变好的。
talk about how someone's language gets better. We don't talk about how their emotional processing or their decision making gets better. And yet here in some instances, people can have brain damage or neurologic disease. And there are changes and changes in a way that some people find more appealing. The point does not that if you get brain damage, your art will get better, but under some circumstances that happens. So we see this in some degenerative
谈论一个人的语言能力是如何变好的。我们不谈论他们的情绪处理或决策能力是如何变好的。然而在这里，在某些情况下，人们可能会有脑损伤或神经系统疾病。并且会出现一些变化，这些变化在某些人看来更具吸引力。重点并不是说如果你脑损伤了，你的艺术水平就会提高，但在某些情况下确实会发生。所以我们在一些退行性疾病中看到了这一点。
conditions, in particularly a group of disorders called front to temporal dementia. It has seen sometimes in people with autism that have very impressive graphic skills, and sometimes in people with Parkinson's disease, especially after they've been put on medications to help with their dopamine system, dopamine agnus. And so why is that? What is going on? What is this telling us about the nature of art, the nature of art production and how it's organized in the brain?
特别是被称为额颞叶痴呆的一组疾病。在患有自闭症但具有非常令人印象深刻的绘画技能的人身上有时也能看到这种情况，有时在帕金森病患者身上也能看到，特别是在他们服用帮助多巴胺系统的药物（多巴胺激动剂）之后。那么这是为什么呢？发生了什么？这告诉了我们关于艺术的本质、艺术创作的本质以及它在大脑中是如何组织起来的什么信息？
Anjun vividly recalls one patient with Parkinson's disease. It's a disorder that is linked to disruptions in the production of the neurotransmitter dopamine. As we have explored in other episodes, dopamine plays an important role in motivation and in the experience of pleasure. Treatments for Parkinson's often involve dopamine agonists, drugs that mimic the effects of dopamine. He, as a young man, had studied graphic design and then had gone into business and so that designed background receded in his everyday life. But then he developed Parkinson's disease and rented space in a studio and found that he kept going back there.
安詹生动地回忆起一位帕金森病患者。这是一种与神经递质多巴胺产生中断有关的疾病。正如我们在其他剧集中探讨的那样，多巴胺在动机和快乐体验中起着重要作用。帕金森病的治疗通常涉及多巴胺激动剂，即模拟多巴胺作用的药物。他年轻时学习过平面设计，后来进入了商界，所以设计背景在他的日常生活中逐渐淡化了。但后来他患上了帕金森病，并在一个工作室租了空间，发现自己不断地回到那里。
And then when he got placed on dopamine agonist, he found it compelling. He gave the example of riding a train where you're presented with a wonderful meal, but your stop is coming up and feeling a compulsion that you have to finish eating your meal to be able to get through it. So he had that feeling with art that there was sort of an urgency to his desire to go to the studio and to basically work on his art? Absolutely. And he would go there at five in the morning and spend 12, 14, 16 hours a day doing his artwork and became really preoccupied with his artwork.
当他开始服用多巴胺激动剂时，他发现这很有吸引力。他举了一个例子，就像坐火车时，你面前有一顿美餐，但你的站快到了，你会感到一种必须吃完这顿饭才能继续下去的冲动。所以他在艺术方面也有这种感觉，即他去工作室并基本上从事艺术创作的欲望有一种紧迫感？绝对是这样。他会在凌晨五点去那里，每天花12、14、16个小时进行艺术创作，并变得非常专注于他的艺术作品。
Can I just stay with that for a second? Did you talk to him and sort of ask him what was going on? Did you have any interactions with him? I mean, to go to sort of discover our sort of relatively late in your life and then have it tone into something of an obsession, that is fascinating. Yeah, we talked him quite a bit. We even went out to his studio to actually see what he was doing. And he would, there would be certain themes that he would focus on and keep working on, keep working on certain kinds
我能就这一点多问一下吗？你和他谈过，问过他发生了什么吗？你和他有过什么互动吗？我的意思是，在你的生活中相对较晚的时候发现这种艺术天赋，然后让它变成一种痴迷，这太迷人了。是的，我们和他谈了很多。我们甚至去了他的工作室，亲眼看看他在做什么。他会有一些他会关注的主题，并不断地研究，不断地研究某些种类的。
of visual themes that would continue to work on. And this is quite characteristic in these conditions. They tended to be somewhat abstract representations. He lived in an apartment that overlooked a city park called Washington Square. And so he had these sets of square images that if you didn't know what they were, you wouldn't necessarily know it was a city park, but there was this kind of geometry built into these squares, for example. Another case, Anjana studied, involved an artist named Catherine Sherwood. She was also a professor at the University of California, Berkeley.
视觉主题，他会继续研究。这在这些疾病中是相当典型的。它们往往是某种抽象的表征。他住的公寓俯瞰着一个叫华盛顿广场的城市公园。所以他有一组方形图像，如果你不知道它们是什么，你不一定会知道那是一个城市公园，但例如，这些正方形中内置了这种几何结构。安詹研究的另一个案例涉及一位名叫凯瑟琳·舍伍德的艺术家。她也是加州大学伯克利分校的教授。
And when she was 44 years old, she was teaching a graduate seminar and had a stroke in the class. Oh my God. Fell down, had a very large left hemisphere stroke. And after that, she had a pretty limited vocabulary initially and couldn't speak very well. And initially was quite depressed and then gradually came out of it and went back to doing her artwork. And her artwork changed and changed in a way that other people have found quite interesting. She herself describes her art as before her stroke having been very meticulous, very analytic, very careful, very controlled, and after her stroke, feeling that there was a looseness of fluidity to her imagery, and that is evident when you look
当她44岁时，她正在教授研究生研讨会，并在课堂上中风了。天哪。倒下了，左半球大面积中风。在那之后，她最初的词汇量相当有限，不能很好地说话。起初非常沮丧，后来逐渐走出来，又回去做她的艺术作品。她的艺术作品发生了变化，而且是以一种其他人觉得非常有趣的方式发生了变化。她自己描述她的艺术，说中风前非常细致、非常分析、非常小心、非常受控，而中风后，她感到她的意象有一种松散的流动性，当你观察时，这一点很明显。
at her art. You know, people have talked for a while about the role of the two hemispheres in the brain, and of course this work has been sometimes oversimplified. But there is some connection between the fact that she had the left hemisphere stroke, in other words her left hemisphere has now been impeded, and the role that neuroscientists have identified the left hemisphere playing in terms of being able to be precise and executing various actions. So in some way she lost precision to some extent, and but perhaps by an additional losing precision, she also gained something in terms of being
在她的艺术作品中。你知道，人们谈论大脑两个半球的作用已经有一段时间了，当然，这项工作有时被过度简化了。但她左半球中风的事实与神经科学家确定的左半球在精确执行各种动作方面的作用之间确实存在某种联系。所以从某种程度上说，她在一定程度上失去了精确度，但也许通过失去精确度，她在某种程度上也获得了一些东西。
less inhibited in terms of what she was depicting. Yes, I think that's right. We do try to emphasize that this idea that has been around a lot of the right hemisphere somehow being dominant for art is, as you say, quite a simplification. Because you can look at people with right brain damage and they also have changes in how they produce art that can be quite striking. And so the point that you're making is that the brain has a certain equilibrium, if you will, between different competing or collaborating
在描绘事物时受到的抑制更少。是的，我认为那是对的。我们确实试图强调，关于右半球在某种程度上主导艺术的这种观点，正如你所说，是一个相当大的简化。因为你可以观察那些右脑受损的人，他们在创作艺术的方式上也有变化，这可能非常引人注目。所以你提出的观点是，大脑在不同的竞争或协作元素之间有一种平衡。
elements. And when you have some kind of brain damage or a stroke or a disorder, some of those elements can be thrown out of whack. And this can sometimes result in just people not being able to perform things and not being able to do things. But you're saying sometimes it can also result in a new equilibrium that is achieved, that produces a different kind of art. Yes, absolutely.
元素。当你遭受某种脑损伤、中风或疾病时，其中一些元素可能会失衡。这有时会导致人们无法执行某些事情，无法做某些事情。但你是在说，有时它也会导致一种新的平衡，从而产生一种不同类型的艺术。是的，绝对是这样。
And I think one of the things that tells us is how art is not just one thing. If you think of famous artists, if you think of a Mark Rothko, that's not the same as what Rembrandt was doing, is not the same as what El Greco was doing, right? So even though we call all of these things art, the nature of the representation, what's trying to be communicated, what the configuration of that can be very, very different. When we come back, scientific experiments that explore how the brain produces art, When we come back, scientific experiments that explore how the brain produces art, experiences art, and is moved by beauty. Also, the $64 million question.
我认为这告诉我们的一件事是，艺术不仅仅是一件事。如果你想到著名的艺术家，如果你想到马克·罗斯科，那和伦勃朗在做的事情不一样，和埃尔·格列柯在做的事情也不一样，对吧？所以即使我们把所有这些东西都称为艺术，表征的本质、试图传达的内容、配置方式都可能非常非常不同。当我们回来时，将探讨大脑如何产生艺术、体验艺术并被美所感动的科学实验。此外，还有那个价值6400万美元的问题。
Why does the human brain care so much about aesthetics? It doesn't make sense. We don't have sex with art, we don't eat art, right? In what sense is this an instinct? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When Anjana's strategy was growing up in India, he spent a lot of time drawing landscapes. He wasn't a neuroscientist at that time, but he found himself asking a question that was very much about the brain.
为什么人类大脑如此关心美学？这说不通。我们不和艺术发生性关系，我们不吃艺术，对吧？从什么意义上说这是一种本能？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。当安詹·查特吉在印度长大时，他花了很多时间画风景画。那时他不是神经科学家，但他发现自己问了一个非常关于大脑的问题。
Why did some landscapes look beautiful, while others did not? After he became a researcher, Anjana decided to study the neuroscience of aesthetic experience. In one study, he evaluated how easily and automatically people make aesthetic judgments. We had a set of faces that were computer-generated so that they weren't defactual people, and we had these faces, nor I haven't done how attractive they were.
为什么有些风景看起来很美，而另一些则不然？成为研究人员后，安詹决定研究审美体验的神经科学。在一项研究中，他评估了人们做出审美判断的容易程度和自动程度。我们有一组计算机生成的面孔，所以它们不是真实的人，我们有这些面孔，我还没有评估它们有多吸引人。
And people came to the scanner in two different sessions. In one condition, they're seeing a series of faces, and they're making a judgment of how attractive they think the faces are. In the other, they're making an identity judgment, which is, have they seen this face before, so it's a familiarity condition. Separately from that, we, in each person, identified certain parts of our visual cortex.
人们在两次不同的会议中来到扫描仪前。在一种情况下，他们看到一系列面孔，并判断他们认为这些面孔有多吸引人。在另一种情况下，他们进行身份判断，也就是他们以前是否见过这张脸，所以这是一个熟悉度条件。除此之外，我们在每个人身上确定了视觉皮层的某些部分。
Our visual cortex tends to be tuned to different aspects of the world. So there's an area called the fused form gyros that is especially tuned to faces and area within the parahipic campus that is tuned to environments. So the first observation is that when people came and they're making judgments of how attractive they think the faces are, where aesthetics is explicitly on the table, what we see is that there is increased neural activity that varies with how attractive the faces are, and not in a generalized way in the sense that the area of the brain that is processing buildings and landscapes is not responsive to this parameter.
我们的视觉皮层倾向于调整到世界的不同方面。所以有一个区域叫梭状回，它特别针对面孔，海马旁回内有一个区域针对环境。所以第一个观察结果是，当人们来到这里并判断他们认为面孔有多吸引人时，当美学明确摆在桌面上时，我们看到神经活动增加，这取决于面孔有多吸引人，而且不是以一种普遍的方式，因为大脑中处理建筑物和风景的区域对这个参数没有反应。
So now that what people are sensitive to attractive faces and you're picking up, to some extent the signature of what this looks like in the brain. Right. And the interesting thing about this experiment is that when people are making an identity judgment, so aesthetics is not on the table. They have the same kind of response to how attractive the faces are within their occipital cortex. So the suggestion being that our visual cortex is responding to whatever value is there
所以现在人们对有吸引力的面孔很敏感，你在某种程度上捕捉到了大脑中这看起来像什么的特征。对。这个实验有趣的地方在于，当人们进行身份判断时，美学并没有摆在桌面上。他们在枕叶皮层内对这些面孔有多吸引人有同样的反应。所以这表明我们的视觉皮层正在对那里存在的任何价值做出反应。
in these attractive faces, even when we are being asked to do something else. Hmm. It's almost like it's operating in the background outside of our control almost automatically. Exactly. It's not to make too much of a pun of it. It is a hidden brain response. Yeah.
在这些有吸引力的面孔中，即使我们被要求做其他事情。嗯。这几乎就像它在后台运行，在我们的控制之外，几乎是自动的。完全正确。这不是为了玩双关语。这是一种隐藏的大脑反应。是的。
So the interesting thing here, of course, is that people are factoring in aesthetic questions or questions about attractiveness, even in domains where it's completely irrelevant or not useful. And of course, this has all kinds of implications for how we behave and walk in the world. But it does point to something that I think is one dimension of how many of us think about beauty, which is we think about beauty in terms of other people.
所以这里有趣的地方当然是，人们正在考虑审美问题或关于吸引力的问题，即使在完全无关或无用的领域。当然，这对我们如何表现和在世界上行走有各种各样的影响。但这确实指出了我认为我们许多人思考美的方式的一个维度，那就是我们从他人的角度思考美。
And all of us have had the experience of seeing someone very beautiful, either on a movie screen or on a television show or in real life and feeling almost our throat's catch or a hot skip a beat because we're so struck by how beautiful they are. Can you just talk a moment about our sensitivity to human beauty as one of our earliest exposures to the nature of beauty itself? Yeah, it's quite striking. Most people have, as you say, this experience of people that we find quite beautiful. And if we think about the words that sometimes we use for attractive people that are similar to beauty, we use words like glamorous and charming and enthralling and chanting.
我们所有人都经历过看到一个非常漂亮的人，无论是在电影屏幕上、电视节目中还是在现实生活中，感到几乎喉咙发紧或心跳加速，因为我们被他们的美丽所震撼。你能谈谈我们对人类美的敏感性作为我们对美本身本质的最早接触之一吗？是的，这非常引人注目。正如你所说，大多数人都有这种经历，即我们发现非常漂亮的人。如果我们思考我们有时用来形容有吸引力的人的词，这些词与美相似，我们使用像迷人、有魅力、令人着迷、令人陶醉这样的词。
These are all magic words. There is a sense in which that there's something magical about this experience. It turns out that people are quite consistent across cultures with the kinds of faces that people find attractive and that we respond to these faces in, as you say, an automatic fashion. It turns out that infants are also responsive to faces that adults think are attractive. So this does seem to be a kind of response that most people have, which is to the attractiveness
这些都是魔法词。在某种意义上，这种体验确实有一些神奇之处。事实证明，人们在不同文化中对人们认为有吸引力的面孔相当一致，而且正如你所说，我们以一种自动的方式对这些面孔做出反应。事实证明，婴儿也对成年人认为有吸引力的面孔有反应。所以这似乎确实是大多数人都有的一种反应，即对人们外表吸引力的反应。
of the way people look. Tell me about the work that's been done on very young children and that perceptions of attractiveness. Yeah, some of this work is really fascinating. It turns out that infants, even younger than six months, will look at faces preferentially or for longer that adults regard as attractive. They will look at them longer and preferentially. Around the age of six months there have been some studies that show that they actually have a category of what is attractive and what is unattractive.
告诉我关于在非常年幼的儿童身上所做的工作以及对吸引力的感知。是的，其中一些工作真的非常迷人。事实证明，婴儿，甚至不到六个月大，会优先或更长时间地注视成年人认为有吸引力的面孔。他们会注视得更久，而且是优先注视。在大约六个月大的时候，有一些研究表明他们实际上有一个关于什么是吸引人、什么是没有吸引力的类别。
And this would suggest in some ways that this is, in some ways not just being influenced by the culture, right? Because presumably these very small infants, they're not reading People magazine and they're not watching Bollywood movies. Yes, that is the inference that we think that there is something core about the way our minds are made up, and there may be some evolutionary arguments to support
这在某种程度上表明，这在某种程度上不仅仅是受到文化的影响，对吧？因为据推测，这些非常小的婴儿，他们不读《人物》杂志，也不看宝莱坞电影。是的，这就是我们认为我们的思维方式有一些核心内容的推论，并且可能有一些进化论的论点来支持。
that. That this is something that is really fundamental in how our brains are organized. I want to talk a moment about why it is our brains come predisposed to perceive aesthetics at all. You can imagine that you could run a brain that basically is able to see things and taste things and navigate the world and have communication, but doesn't sit in front of a painting at a not museum or listen for two hours to a musical concert or it seems at some level Subrofluous to basically say we spend so much of our time You know caring about what is beautiful in the world and many of us spend enormous amounts of time caring about what's beautiful What are your theories about why it is we have this capacity in the brain in the first place? Yeah, so the general idea is that we
这一点。这确实是我们大脑组织方式中非常根本的东西。我想谈谈为什么我们的大脑天生就倾向于感知美学。你可以想象，你可以运行一个大脑，它基本上能够看到事物、品尝事物、在世界上导航并进行交流，但不会坐在博物馆的画作前，也不会花两个小时听音乐会，或者在某种程度上说，我们花这么多时间关心世界上什么是美的，这似乎是多余的，我们许多人花大量时间关心什么是美的。关于为什么我们大脑中首先具备这种能力，你有什么理论？是的，所以总的想法是，我们。
over Long periods of time adapt to our environment and adapt in a way that helps us survive and helps us have children that survive. And when it comes to what we find attractive in other people, the idea is that the parameters that we tend to find beautiful were also indicators of health, which meant the greater possibility of having more children, which meant that those kinds of preference and trait combinations get propagated in a population. So what does this mean for sort of physical attractiveness, for example? trade combinations get propagated in a population.
在很长一段时间内适应了我们的环境，并以一种帮助我们生存并帮助我们拥有能够生存的后代的方式进行适应。当谈到我们在他人身上发现什么是吸引人时，我们的想法是，我们倾向于认为美丽的参数也是健康的指标，这意味着拥有更多后代的可能性更大，这意味着这些偏好和特征组合在人群中得到传播。那么这对身体吸引力意味着什么呢？特征组合在人群中得到传播。
So what does this mean for physical attractiveness, for example? So what this means, for example, is that the sorts of parameters for physical attractiveness in faces have tended to be symmetry. The idea there is that this is a marker for immunocompetence in the sense that during this long period before the modern era that we tended to die from infectious causes, parasites that typically whether it's in plants or animals or humans tend to be disfiguring, so there is that. The theory in other words is that we're drawn to symmetry because symmetry serves as a signal of health.
那么这对身体吸引力意味着什么呢？所以这意味着，例如，面部身体吸引力的参数往往是对称性。那里的想法是，这是免疫能力的标志，因为在现代时代之前的这段漫长时期，我们倾向于死于传染病，寄生虫通常无论是在植物、动物还是人类中往往是毁容的，所以有这一点。换句话说，理论是我们被对称性所吸引，因为对称性是健康的信号。
Another trait that Anjana and others have found people are drawn to is something called averaging. That if you have a bunch of faces and you combine them, which we can now do digitally quite easily, that the averaged face tends to be more attractive than the individual faces contributing to the averaging. The idea is that this might represent a greater genetic mix, right? You've got these phenotypes, how people look, that are being combined, suggesting that you've got a more diverse and robust genetic profile, which improves your immune system. So that also promotes
安詹和其他人发现人们被吸引的另一个特征被称为平均化。如果你有一堆面孔并将它们结合起来，我们现在可以很容易地数字化地做到这一点，那么平均后的面孔往往比构成平均的单个面孔更具吸引力。这个想法是，这可能代表了更大的基因混合，对吧？你拥有这些表型，人们看起来的样子，正在被结合，这表明你拥有更多样化和更强大的基因图谱，这改善了你的免疫系统。所以这也促进了。
health. And so I want to be clear, it's not the case. We don't expect that 17, 18, 19-year-old is looking at someone and saying, oh, I think that person is really healthy. That's why I'm attracted to them. That that's a kind of epiphenomenon outcome of these kinds of traits that the hypothetical groups of people who found those features attractive were more likely to survive over long periods of time. At least that's the kind of ideas that people use when we talk about the evolution of beauty and people. And in some ways, I guess, sort of the evolution of beauty in people. And in some ways, I guess sort of the extension
健康。所以我想明确一点，事实并非如此。我们不指望那个17、18、19岁的人看着某人说，哦，我认为那个人真的很健康。这就是我被他们吸引的原因。这是一种这些特征的附带现象结果，即那些发现这些特征有吸引力的假设人群在很长一段时间内更有可能生存下来。至少这就是人们在谈论人类美的进化时使用的那种想法。在某种程度上，我想，人类美的进化。在某种程度上，我想，这种论点的延伸。
of this argument would be that once the brain comes predisposed to see sort of other humans as beautiful or not beautiful, or to take pleasure in food, for example, then you have to have the architecture in the brain that is able to process, you know, has visual processing and the experience of a reward or the experience of pleasure. And in some ways art sort of sits on top of those things. Can you talk about that idea that in some
会是，一旦大脑天生倾向于将其他人视为美丽或不美丽，或者例如从食物中获得快乐，那么你就必须拥有大脑中能够处理的架构，你知道，拥有视觉处理和奖励体验或快乐体验。在某种程度上，艺术某种程度上建立在这些事物之上。你能谈谈那个想法吗，在某种程度上。
ways art might also be downstream of some of these more basic evolutionary phenomena? Yeah, I think that's exactly right. And we can put architecture in there as well. So, the empirical evidence suggests that when you look at faces and landscapes, natural landscapes, people tend to be quite consistent. When you look at human artifacts, which be art, and then architecture falls somewhere in between landscapes and art, people are much more variable. And so I think the kinds of pleasures we can get from art and architecture rests on those very primitive and basic systems, but art and architecture are also more variable, and
艺术也可能是这些更基本的进化现象的下游？是的，我认为这完全正确。我们也可以把建筑放在那里。所以，经验证据表明，当你观察面孔和风景、自然景观时，人们往往相当一致。当你观察人类制品，也就是艺术，然后建筑介于风景和艺术之间，人们的变化要大得多。所以我认为我们能从艺术和建筑中获得的快乐建立在那些非常原始和基本的系统之上，但艺术和建筑也更具可变性，并且。
this is where the kind of cultural overlay, the personal meaning, the personal histories, also has an effect on something that is already riding on a more fundamental and basic set of relationships between our sensory perceptions and the rewards that we get from them. A few years ago I was invited to give a talk in London at the Royal Society of Medicine on aesthetics. And the person who invited me was an ophthalmologist and we're walking along a particular part of London is very organized. Everything is off-white, very geometric. And he just commented on, isn't this beautiful? And if you grew up in India or in places,
这就是文化叠加、个人意义、个人历史也对已经建立在我们感官知觉和我们从中获得的奖励之间更基本和基础的关系之上的事物产生影响的地方。几年前，我受邀在伦敦的皇家医学会就美学发表演讲。邀请我的人是一位眼科医生，我们走在伦敦的一个特定区域，非常整洁。一切都是灰白色的，非常几何化。他只是评论说，这不美吗？如果你在印度或在某些地方长大。
probably in the global South, the first question is, where's the color? There's no color, right? I can appreciate in a desiccated way how coherent and organized this was, and there's a pattern to it. But for me, the absence of color was a problem. And so that's just a simple example of how our cultural backgrounds and what we're used to can have an effect on our experience with the same environment. on our experience with the same environment. Anjane and his colleagues argue that aesthetic appreciation in the brain is shaped by what
可能是在全球南方，第一个问题是，颜色在哪里？没有颜色，对吧？我可以以一种枯燥的方式欣赏这是多么连贯和有组织，并且它有一种模式。但对我来说，缺乏颜色是一个问题。所以这只是一个简单的例子，说明我们的文化背景和我们习惯的东西如何对我们在同一环境中的体验产生影响。在同一环境中的体验。安詹和他的同事认为，大脑中的审美欣赏是由他们所说的审美三元组塑造的。
they call an aesthetic triad. Brighter colors are more arresting than dull colors. Artistic expression that hooks into the centers of the brain that process emotions and meaning is more evocative than art that does not. And in the physical domain, skilled movement stimulates parts of our brains that control motor activity. This is why it can feel beautiful to watch a graceful dancer or an athlete. I follow a basketball quite a bit and there is this combination of athleticism and grace and beauty and amazement, the kind of control of somebody's body that one can have when I was in college, Julius
更明亮的颜色比暗淡的颜色更引人注目。与大脑中处理情绪和意义的中心挂钩的艺术表达比不这样做的艺术更具感染力。在物理领域，熟练的动作刺激我们大脑中控制运动活动的部位。这就是为什么观看优雅的舞者或运动员会感觉很美。我经常关注篮球，有一种运动能力、优雅、美丽和惊奇的结合，当我在大学时，朱利叶斯。
Irving, played in Philadelphia, and he was even called Dr. J as a way of acknowledging his skill and his mastery. And he seemed to defy laws of physics the way he could hang and the way his body could twist in air and there's a beauty to that. Here's Julie, yes. Yes, sir, the doctor. Boy, what a move. Take that one.
欧文在费城打球，他甚至被称为J博士，以此来承认他的技能和精湛技艺。他似乎违背了物理定律，他能在空中悬停的方式以及他身体扭曲的方式，这有一种美感。这是朱利叶斯，是的。是的，先生，医生。天哪，多棒的动作。拿走那个。
When I watched Dr. J soaring through the air, it's as if gravity doesn't apply to him. I can't help but feel a sense of wonder. I'm clearly not alone, judging from the millions of views of YouTube videos of Dr. J playing basketball. I feel much the same when I watch the world's best soccer players score impossible goals or athletes perform dazzling feats at the Olympics. People will sometimes refer to soccer as the beautiful game. You can look at some runners, some jumpers and their form there is a grace and an elegance to their movements that can be breathtaking.
当我看着J博士在空中翱翔时，就好像重力对他不适用一样。我不禁感到一种惊奇。从YouTube上J博士打篮球视频的数百万次观看来看，我显然并不孤单。当我看着世界上最好的足球运动员打进不可能的进球，或者运动员在奥运会上表演令人眼花缭乱的壮举时，我也有同样的感觉。人们有时会把足球称为美丽的运动。你可以看看一些跑步者、一些跳跃者，他们的形式有一种优雅和优美，令人叹为观止。
Oh, good job! Yes, I think he's happy with that! That toy, buddy! I think there are at least two components, which is the elegance of movement, which you also see, for example, among dancers. And then there is a kind of mastery that we also find very appealing and sometimes we have this feeling with very accomplished artists that there is a skill and a mastery that can be quite striking, especially people that are performing at the highest levels of their sport.
哦，干得好！是的，我想他对那个很满意！那个玩具，伙计！我认为至少有两个组成部分，即动作的优雅，你也可以在舞者中看到这一点。然后还有一种我们觉得非常有吸引力的精湛技艺，有时我们对非常有成就的艺术家有这种感觉，即有一种技能和精湛技艺，这可能非常引人注目，特别是那些在运动中表现出最高水平的人。
at the highest levels of their sport. Can we talk a little bit about the aesthetics involved in science and in mathematics? Because I think you've done something about this as well, that in some ways we can perceive mathematical constructs or ideas to also be beautiful in the same way that he can perceive, you know, Julius Irving on the basketball court, or, you know, a supermodel on a fashion cover, that it has sort of the same effect on us. Can you talk about that and why that might be the case? Why would, you know, you could sort of, you know, draw a connection between, you know, the supermodel and perhaps the athlete and sort of some of the evolutionary things that we talked about, the potential connections with survival and reproduction,
在他们运动的最高水平。我们能谈谈科学和数学中涉及的美学吗？因为我想你也做过这方面的工作，在某种程度上，我们可以感知数学结构或思想也是美丽的，就像他可以感知，你知道，朱利叶斯·欧文在篮球场上，或者，你知道，时尚封面上的超级名模，它对我们有同样的效果。你能谈谈这一点以及为什么会这样吗？为什么，你知道，你可以某种程度上，你知道，在超级名模和运动员以及我们谈论的一些进化事物之间建立联系，与生存和繁殖的潜在联系。
why in the world would we find chess strategies beautiful or mathematics beautiful or scientific equations or the theory of evolution or things that sort of summarize or explain the world? Why would we have similar aesthetic experiences about those things, Enchen? Yeah, it's a fascinating question. If we go back to the aesthetic triad and we think about mathematics or strategies and chess,
为什么世界上我们会发现国际象棋策略是美丽的，或者数学是美丽的，或者科学方程或进化论或总结或解释世界的事物是美丽的？为什么我们对那些事物会有类似的审美体验，安詹？是的，这是一个迷人的问题。如果我们回到审美三元组，我们思考数学或国际象棋中的策略。
this is really about the kind of the meaning and the semantics part of it, right? There's no obvious sensory qualities to this, right? So somehow meaning is driving this kind of pleasure that we get from these relationships. And one possibility is that that kind of coherence that's produced in something that otherwise might appear to be chaotic is a kind of aha-ha, a feeling of, oh, there's some elegance to this, right?
这实际上是关于意义和语义的部分，对吧？这没有明显的感官品质，对吧？所以某种意义上，意义正在驱动我们从这些关系中获得的这种快乐。一种可能性是，在否则可能看起来混乱的事物中产生的那种连贯性是一种“啊哈”的感觉，一种“哦，这有一些优雅”的感觉，对吧？
In all of this chaos, there's something coherent that if we understood it, then we find it to be beautiful. You know, the developmental psychologist, Alison Gopnik, she's talking about this in infants and how when infants infants when they understand something their face lights up with joy, right? There's a joy to understanding and it may be that the particular predisposition to get joy out of explanation right allowed people to look at complex phenomena and understand them and
在所有这些混乱中，有一些连贯的东西，如果我们理解了它，那么我们就会发现它是美丽的。你知道，发展心理学家艾莉森·高普尼克，她在谈论婴儿时，当婴儿理解某事时，他们的脸会因喜悦而发光，对吧？理解有一种喜悦，可能正是从解释中获得喜悦的特殊倾向，允许人们观察复杂的现象并理解它们，并且。
then be able to predict what might happen in a way that has survival value. In this telling, our aesthetic appreciation is a byproduct of what is functional. If the ability to admire graceful footwork on a soccer field or makes sense of the world in a mathematical equation or spot a good-looking person across the room, increases our chances of survival and reproduction, our brains will be sculpted by evolution to derive pleasure from doing those things.
然后能够以一种具有生存价值的方式预测可能发生的事情。在这种叙述中，我们的审美欣赏是功能性的副产品。如果欣赏足球场上优雅的步法或理解数学方程中的世界或发现房间对面好看的人的能力，增加了我们生存和繁殖的机会，我们的大脑就会被进化塑造，从而从做这些事情中获得快乐。
Beauty, in other words, is a by-product of what is useful. When we come back, a different perspective. Is it possible that beauty is not just a product of our minds, but an objective feature of the universe? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Frank Wilcheck is a theoretical physicist and mathematician at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology. In 2004, he won the Nobel Prize for his work on quantum
换句话说，美是有用的副产品。当我们回来时，一个不同的视角。美不仅仅是我们思想的产物，而是宇宙的一个客观特征，这可能吗？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。弗兰克·维尔切克是麻省理工学院的理论物理学家和数学家。2004年，他因在量子色动力学方面的工作获得了诺贝尔奖。
chromodynamics. But long before he was a Nobel Prize winner, Frank was a curious kid who enjoyed tinkering with everyday objects. One of his earliest memories involves taking apart his father's coffee percolator. I was on the floor and the percolator was on the floor and it had seven pieces and there were big pieces, so I could handle it, take them apart and put it back together. And this idea of things making sense and that you could take them apart
但在他成为诺贝尔奖得主很久之前，弗兰克是一个好奇的孩子，喜欢摆弄日常物品。他最早的记忆之一涉及拆开他父亲的咖啡过滤器。我当时在地板上，过滤器在地板上，它有七个部分，而且是大块的，所以我可以处理它，把它们拆开并重新组装起来。这种事物有意义的想法，你可以把它们拆开。
and put them together and that I could take them apart and put them together made it a big impression on me. In fact, it was sort of at that moment that I realized that there was an inner world and an outer world, that they were different things, you know, that I could manipulate the world to a certain extent. When Frank was a bit older, he became fascinated by something called the Hurtsprung Russell Diagram. was a bit older, he became fascinated by something called the Hertz-prung Russell Diagram. It's a chart that scientists use to plot stars based on their temperature and brightness. Hider stars tend to be brighter, but not necessarily because they might also be small.
并把它们组装起来，我可以把它们拆开并重新组装起来，这给我留下了深刻的印象。事实上，就在那一刻，我意识到有一个内在世界和一个外在世界，它们是不同的东西，你知道，我可以在一定程度上操纵世界。当弗兰克大一点时，他迷上了赫茨普龙-罗素图。这是一种科学家用来根据恒星的温度和亮度绘制恒星图表的图表。较热的恒星往往更亮，但不一定，因为它们也可能很小。
So these are really separate things. And what turns out is that in this diagram, the dots, they could have been scattered all over the plane, but they actually form a couple of arcs that you can interpret as stars that have different structures. I don't think I understood the details at the time, but just the idea that at the time, but just the idea that you could find regularities and understand them based on profound physical principles. It made a big impression on the, that gee, I'd like to really understand that. Yeah, you know, all of us have seen, I think, textbooks where we see the description of stars and the cosmos, and we see how these can be explained on the page with mathematical equations.
所以这些确实是独立的事情。事实证明，在这个图中，点，它们本可以散布在整个平面上，但它们实际上形成了几个弧线，你可以将其解释为具有不同结构的恒星。我不认为我当时理解细节，但只是那个想法。当时，你可以找到规律并根据深刻的物理原理理解它们。这给我留下了深刻的印象，天哪，我真的很想理解这一点。是的，你知道，我们所有人都看过，我想，教科书，我们在那里看到恒星和宇宙的描述，我们看到这些如何在页面上用数学方程来解释。
But I think what you're pointing at is actually how remarkable this is, that in fact, you're describing things that are millions, hundreds of millions of light years away, and something on a page is able to capture something true about something that is literally astronomically far away. Yeah, but to me, it goes even deeper than that, the fact that you can make a precise mapping between concepts and reality. That, to me, is the central miracle of the scientific revolution that we shouldn't settle for anything less than a really profound understanding. And the fact that you can extrapolate that not only to things we can measure in a laboratory, but to stars and the cosmos is just sort of the cherry on the Sunday of this miracle.
但我认为你指出的实际上是这有多么了不起，事实上，你正在描述数百万、数亿光年之外的事物，而页面上的东西能够捕捉到关于字面上天文距离之外的事物的真实情况。是的，但对我来说，它比那更深入，你可以建立概念和现实之间的精确映射的事实。对我来说，那是科学革命的核心奇迹，我们不应该满足于任何低于真正深刻理解的东西。而且你可以将其推断到不仅是我们可以在实验室中测量的东西，而且是恒星和宇宙的事实，这只是这个奇迹圣代上的樱桃。
miracle. In the 1970s, Frank began studying physics at Princeton. As he learned about the famous discoveries of the 20th century, he realized there was a curious connection between the worlds of science and aesthetics. In 20th century physics, as people started to investigate the insides of atoms, experiments became much more difficult. So, sort of a data-driven account of the world became very much more difficult to pull off. The data is hard to get. And what turned out to be the right strategy was to guess that there might be a simple, beautiful underlying description, and then work out its consequences enough so that people could do a few experiments to test if the ideas were right.
奇迹。20世纪70年代，弗兰克开始在普林斯顿学习物理。当他了解20世纪的著名发现时，他意识到科学和美学世界之间存在一种奇妙的联系。在20世纪的物理学中，当人们开始研究原子的内部时，实验变得困难得多。所以，一种数据驱动的世界观变得更难实现了。数据很难获得。事实证明，正确的策略是猜测可能存在一个简单、美丽的基础描述，然后推导出其后果，足以让人们做一些实验来测试这些想法是否正确。
And this process of guessing, how do you guess? Well, you guess, first of all, you have to be consistent with everything we know, so that's very constrained, kind of guessing. But secondly, you look for things that are beautiful. You look for things that are symmetrical, that are compact. These kinds of aesthetic considerations have more and more come to dominate how people try to find new laws of fundamental physics. fundamental physics. Hmm. Hmm.
关于这种猜测的过程，你是怎么猜的呢？嗯，首先，你必须与我们已知的一切保持一致，所以这是一种非常受限的猜测。但其次，你要寻找那些美丽的事物。你要寻找那些对称的、紧凑的事物。这些审美层面的考量在人们试图寻找基础物理学新定律的过程中，变得越来越重要。基础物理学。嗯。嗯。
So, let me unpack two things here, because this is really interesting. What you're saying is that at some level, once the experimental data turned out to be limited, it became easier in some ways to come up with theories, but in fact, the theories could have gone in any number of different directions, and so the choice becomes which of these theories do you think is more likely or more plausible? And you're suggesting that many scientists in the course of the 20th century chose the theories that seemed aesthetically pleasing or parsimonious at least as a guide to the truth? Well, people try all different kinds of things, but the thing that actually worked
那么，让我来拆解一下这两点，因为这真的很有趣。你的意思是，在某种程度上，一旦实验数据变得有限，在某些方面提出理论就变得更容易了，但事实上，这些理论可能走向任何不同的方向，所以选择就变成了你认为哪种理论更可能或更合理？你是说20世纪的许多科学家在选择理论时，至少把看起来美观或简洁作为通往真理的指南吗？嗯，人们尝试了各种各样的东西，但真正起作用的
and broke through in the field was guessing some beautiful equations based on a few crucial facts and then sticking with those equations and even though at first we could calculate very very little they seem to be okay and now we can calculate a lot. One beautiful equation all of us are familiar with is E equals MC squared. Einstein's special theory of relativity explains how speed and mass affect time and space. When Einstein proposed this theory in the early 1900s, there was limited data to support it. But Einstein was guided by a preference for simplicity and elegance in his scientific pursuits.
并在该领域取得突破的方法是，基于几个关键事实猜测出一些优美的方程，然后坚持使用这些方程。尽管起初我们能计算的东西非常非常少，但它们似乎是正确的，现在我们可以计算很多东西了。我们都熟悉的一个优美方程是E=mc²。爱因斯坦的狭义相对论解释了速度和质量如何影响时间和空间。当爱因斯坦在20世纪初提出这个理论时，支持它的数据非常有限。但爱因斯坦在科学追求中受到对简洁和优雅的偏好的引导。
As the physicist Wolfgang Rindler wrote, to equate all mass with energy required an act of aesthetic faith, very characteristic of Einstein. Decades after Einstein proposed E equals MC squared, Frank and his colleagues were searching for another equation, one that would describe what happens inside the nucleus of an atom. In case you're not a quantum physicist, let me attempt to translate what Frank is saying. Imagine the nucleus of an atom is a tiny room filled with positively charged protons. Because these protons all have the same charge,
正如物理学家沃尔夫冈·林德勒所写，将所有质量与能量等同起来需要一种审美信仰，这是爱因斯坦非常典型的特征。在爱因斯坦提出E=mc²几十年后，弗兰克和他的同事们正在寻找另一个方程，一个能描述原子核内部发生什么的方程。如果你不是量子物理学家，让我试着翻译一下弗兰克在说什么。想象一下，原子核是一个装满带正电质子的小房间。因为这些质子都带有相同的电荷，
they should be repelling each other, like magnets that push each other away. But this doesn't happen in the tiny room. Instead, a mysterious force holds the protons together like a very strong glue. It seems to defy the existing laws of physics. People did all kinds of experiments to try to elucidate what this force was, and it got very complicated very fast, so there was no clear path forward.
它们应该会互相排斥，就像互相推开的磁铁一样。但这并没有在这个小房间里发生。相反，一种神秘的力量像强力胶一样把质子粘在一起。这似乎违背了现有的物理定律。人们做了各种各样的实验来试图阐明这种力是什么，而且很快就变得非常复杂，所以没有明确的前进道路。
Until I would say, in retrospect, it's much clearer, that the decisive experiments were done starting in the late 1960s when people learned how to make snapshots of what's going on inside protons. Frank set out to solve the mystery of what was happening inside the nucleus of the atom. And that showed that protons are made out of smaller things, what we call quarks. There were hints of this before, but not wasn't really clear. And there was also something else that had to hold the quarks together,
直到我可以说，回想起来，更清楚的是，决定性的实验始于20世纪60年代末，当时人们学会了如何拍摄质子内部发生的事情的快照。弗兰克着手解开原子核内部发生什么的谜团。这表明质子是由更小的东西组成的，我们称之为夸克。之前有一些暗示，但并不真正清楚。而且还有别的东西必须把夸克固定在一起，
and these were called gluons, but no one knew what they were. And so we wanted to guess equations that did justice to the behavior that those experiments were revealing. Under these snapshots, Frank and his colleagues tried to explain how these particles behaved. There was this very strange behavior of the quarks that they had, the forces become weak when they are close together but get stronger as they get far apart. So this is very different from gravity, for instance, or electromagnetic forces, which get stronger as you go to shorter distances.
这些被称为胶子，但没人知道它们是什么。所以我们想猜测出能够公正对待这些实验所揭示的行为的方程。在这些快照下，弗兰克和他的同事们试图解释这些粒子是如何表现的。夸克有一种非常奇怪的行为，当它们靠近时力会变弱，但当它们远离时力会变强。所以这与引力或电磁力非常不同，后者在距离越短时力越强。
And it's more like the behavior of rubber bands, right? The force gets very flaccid when they're close together. But they get tense when you try to pull them very far apart. And that's what we started. We made a breakthrough discovery of a force that started to behave this way, started to get weaker as you go towards shorter distances and higher energies. This was my first serious investigation in physics or anything really. I was 21 years old. I didn't have a lot of experience. I didn't know what to expect. I was quite conscious of the fact that we were making very bold extrapolations based on a few experiments
这更像是橡皮筋的行为，对吧？当它们靠近时，力变得非常松弛。但当你试图把它们拉得很远时，它们就会变得紧张。这就是我们开始的地方。我们发现了一种开始以这种方式表现的力，这是一种突破性的发现，它在向更短距离和更高能量移动时开始变弱。这是我在物理学或任何领域进行的第一次严肃研究。我当时21岁。我没有太多经验。我不知道会发生什么。我非常清楚我们在基于少数实验进行非常大胆的推断，
and ignoring the vast bulk of experimental physics. It was risky, but Frank and his colleagues stuck their next out. They proposed a new model for the inner workings of the atom. We were led to a unique candidate set of equations, which is now called quantum electrodynamics. And as in the cases we've discussed before, at first the data was very sparse, very difficult to interpret. Very few people believed us. I'm not sure I believed it myself, but people did experiments at higher energies and then the picture clarifies a lot because the
并忽略了绝大多数实验物理学。这很冒险，但弗兰克和他的同事们冒了险。他们为原子的内部运作提出了一个新模型。我们被引导到一个独特的候选方程组，现在被称为量子电动力学。正如我们之前讨论的情况一样，起初数据非常稀少，非常难以解释。很少有人相信我们。我不确定我自己是否相信，但人们在更高的能量下做了实验，然后情况变得清晰了很多，因为
behavior gets simpler and you can actually see the quarks, see the gluons, check that they have the properties that these equations predict. And so it's a great success story. Do you think you were guided by aesthetics in your discovery of these equations or do you think after you discover the equations, they look beautiful because, in fact, they are beautiful because they're so simple or so parsimonious. No. It would be impossible to conceive of the equations
行为变得更简单了，你实际上可以看到夸克，看到胶子，检查它们是否具有这些方程所预测的属性。所以这是一个伟大的成功故事。你认为你在发现这些方程时受到了美学的引导吗？还是你认为在你发现方程之后，它们看起来很美，因为事实上，它们确实很美，因为它们如此简单或如此简洁？不。如果不寻找数学美，就不可能构思出这些方程。
without looking for mathematical beauty. These equations are embodiments of symmetry, and that's the only way they could have been discovered practically. You and others have sort of talked about two elements of things that make mathematics and physics beautiful. One of them is symmetry, and the other one is efficiency. And I'm wondering if we can talk about each of these in turn.
这些方程是对称性的体现，这是它们在实践中被发现的唯一途径。你和其他人谈论过使数学和物理学变得美丽的两个要素。一个是对称性，另一个是效率。我想知道我们是否可以依次谈谈这两点。
Talk about the idea of symmetry, Frank. Yeah, well, in common language symmetry has kind of fuzzy meaning, but in science, we need more definite concepts. So the concept of symmetry that's turned out to be fruitful is change without change. Now, what does that mean? Well, for example, a circle is very symmetrical because, with this definition, because you can rotate it around its center by any angle.
谈谈对称性的概念吧，弗兰克。是的，嗯，在通俗语言中，对称性有一种模糊的含义，但在科学中，我们需要更明确的概念。事实证明，富有成效的对称性概念是“变化中的不变”。现在，这是什么意思？嗯，例如，一个圆是非常对称的，因为根据这个定义，你可以绕着它的中心旋转任意角度。
And although every point on it moves, the circle as a whole does not. So you make a change that doesn't change things. And that concept can be applied not only to shapes, but to equations and to laws. As we discussed briefly before, in 20th century physics, it's turned out that the successful equations have been equations based on extraordinarily large amounts
虽然圆上的每个点都在移动，但整个圆并没有改变。所以你做了一个不改变事物的改变。这个概念不仅可以应用于形状，还可以应用于方程和定律。正如我们之前简要讨论的那样，在20世纪物理学中，事实证明成功的方程都是基于极其大量的
of symmetry. Can you talk about the idea of efficiency? And people think of efficiency in sort of a productivity sense. I was efficient, or this company works efficiently, but you're using it, perhaps similarly, but also somewhat differently. Why is efficiency a measure of beauty? The idea is that you can have a very compact set of principles
对称性的方程。你能谈谈效率的概念吗？人们从生产力的意义上考虑效率。我效率很高，或者这家公司运作高效，但你使用它时，也许类似，但也有些不同。为什么效率是美的衡量标准？这个想法是，你可以拥有一套非常紧凑的原则
or program, if you like, in different contexts, that when you unfold its consequences, explains an enormous amount or produces an enormous amount. For example, think about the theory of evolution. It has a few basic principles. Organisms reproduce, their offspring come in variants, and natural selection causes some variants to become numerous. This simple concept applied over billions of years has produced the endless forms most beautiful that Charles Darwin wrote about, the vast canopy of life forms on Earth.
或程序（如果你愿意的话），在不同的背景下，当你展开其后果时，可以解释大量事物或产生大量成果。例如，想想进化论。它有几个基本原则。生物体繁殖，它们的后代会出现变异，自然选择导致一些变异变得众多。这个简单的概念在数十亿年的时间里应用，产生了查尔斯·达尔文所写的“无尽的形式最美丽”，即地球上广阔的生命形式冠层。
And the fact that that can be done is extraordinarily beautiful because you get you get you get out more than you put in and It's also very empowering because It enables you to do things that you couldn't do before I'm wondering whether you've given any thought Frank to why it is that beauty might in fact be a Guide to the truth. As you pointed out earlier, there's no reason why things that are beautiful have to be true.
而且能够做到这一点的事实是非常美丽的，因为你得到的比你投入的多，而且它也非常赋能，因为它使你能够做以前做不到的事情。我想知道你是否考虑过为什么美实际上可能是通往真理的指南。正如你之前指出的，没有理由说美丽的事物一定是真实的。
Have you given any thought to why? In fact, there might be a connection. Oh yeah, I've given a lot of thought to it. And I think it probably has a lot to do with evolution and the fact that what is beauty after all? It's a human concept and people define it in different ways, but certainly part of the meaning, and maybe the essence of it is,
你有没有想过为什么？事实上，可能存在某种联系。哦，是的，我对此思考了很多。我认为这可能与进化有很大关系，毕竟什么是美？这是一个人类概念，人们以不同的方式定义它，但肯定含义的一部分，也许是它的本质是，
something is beautiful if we like to come back to it and interact with it. And it can be useful in getting around with the world and having offspring that survive and survive is being able to understand how the world works. The fact that we find it beautiful to have explanations of how the world works, I don't think is an accident because we're evolved to try to understand how things
如果我们要回到它并与它互动，那么某物就是美丽的。它在应对世界和拥有能够生存的后代方面可能很有用，而生存就是能够理解世界是如何运作的。我们发现拥有解释世界如何运作的理论是美丽的，我认为这并非偶然，因为我们进化到试图理解事物
work. Yeah, we're sent with sense making creatures as psychologists would say. Right. Yeah, so we were so we impose structure on the world and we try to deal deeper and deeper. I guess the miracle part is that it's worked so as well as it has. I think Einstein said, said it right. He said, the most incomprehensible thing about the world is that it's comprehensible, which is don't know why. And it's just a gift. Some time ago, Frank was spending time in Arizona when he experienced some pain in his abdomen. At first, he thought it was an upset stomach, but the pain persisted. In fact, it got worse and worse. Late one evening he found himself in an emergency room in Phoenix.
是如何运作的。是的，正如心理学家所说，我们是意义构建的生物。对。是的，所以我们将结构强加于世界，并试图挖掘得越来越深。我想奇迹的部分在于它运作得如此之好。我想爱因斯坦说得对。他说，关于世界最不可理解的事情是它是可理解的，这不知道为什么。这只是一份礼物。前段时间，弗兰克在亚利桑那州时，腹部感到一些疼痛。起初，他以为是胃部不适，但疼痛持续存在。事实上，它变得越来越严重。一天深夜，他发现自己在凤凰城的一间急诊室里。
Oh gosh, what an awful place. It really made me think about Dante's in Furnum, these paintings of suffering people. There were people in all different kinds of distress. It was very, very slow. And I was in pain the whole time, also. As a turned out, Frank's Godbladder needed to be removed. He would need an operation. The thing that helped me a lot there was actually thinking about the kinds of themes
哦天哪，真是个可怕的地方。它真的让我想起了但丁的《地狱篇》，那些受苦的人的画作。那里有各种各样痛苦的人。非常非常慢。而且我一直都很痛苦。事实证明，弗兰克的胆囊需要切除。他需要做手术。在那里对我帮助很大的一件事实际上是思考我们一直在谈论的那些主题，
that we've been talking about that the world really is a beautiful place. We can understand it. It's enormous and my problems are loom very, very small in the big picture. I mean, and in some ways do you try and carry that through with you not just when you are in an emergency room in Phoenix but through your daily life, Frank, do you try and sort of keep the world in perspective? Oh yes, all the time. And I know I realize that I can rely on that as a source of solace and perspective and calm in distressing circumstances. I'm starting to... Frank Wilcheck is a theoretical physicist and mathematician at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology.
即世界确实是一个美丽的地方。我们可以理解它。它是巨大的，我的问题在大局中显得非常非常小。我的意思是，在某种程度上，你是否试图不仅在凤凰城的急诊室里，而且在你的日常生活中也带着这种观点，弗兰克，你是否试图保持对世界的视角？哦，是的，一直都是。我知道我意识到我可以依靠它作为在痛苦环境中寻求慰藉、视角和冷静的源泉。我开始……弗兰克·维尔切克是麻省理工学院的理论物理学家和数学家。
He won the Nobel Prize in 2004 for his work on quantum chromodynamics, a theory that explains the inner workings of very tiny particles. Frank, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, it's been fun. When someone sees the world as beautiful, it's easy to shrug off their perspective. We say they are naive or shallow, or that they are looking at reality through roasted and glasses. But Frank and many other scientists
他因在量子色动力学方面的工作获得了2004年诺贝尔奖，该理论解释了微小粒子的内部运作。弗兰克，非常感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。谢谢，这很有趣。当有人认为世界是美丽的时候，很容易对他们的观点不屑一顾。我们说他们天真或肤浅，或者他们戴着玫瑰色的眼镜看现实。但弗兰克和许多其他科学家
offer an intriguing counter-argument. The universe itself is roasted in. The poet John Keats may have been onto something when he wrote, beauty is truth, truth beauty. That's all you know on earth, and all you need to know. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz,
提出了一个有趣的反对论点。宇宙本身就是玫瑰色的。诗人约翰·济慈在写下“美即是真，真即是美。这就是你在地球上所知道的一切，也是你需要知道的一切”时，可能已经触及了某种真理。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quarelle、Ryan Katz、
Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our aunts sun heroes today are Derek Blackburn of Quiet House Recording and Daniel Fox of Wonder Smith Audio. Derek and Daniel are audio engineers and they were incredibly generous with their time and knowledge as we were setting up interviews for this episode. Thanks to you both for your help, Derek and Daniel.
Autumn Barnes、Andrew Chadwick和Nick Woodbury。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是Quiet House Recording的Derek Blackburn和Wonder Smith Audio的Daniel Fox。Derek和Daniel是音频工程师，在我们为这一集安排采访时，他们非常慷慨地贡献了时间和知识。感谢你们两位的帮助，Derek和Daniel。
Next week, we continue our look at beauty and why we are so drawn to it. We'll explore the conclusions we draw about people based on their appearance and how those assumptions impact our lives. I mean, it really says a lot about how these impressions that we make about another person based on, you know, appearance have profound consequences, even if those impressions are
下周，我们将继续探讨美以及我们为什么会被它吸引。我们将探讨我们基于外表对他人得出的结论，以及这些假设如何影响我们的生活。我的意思是，这确实说明了我们基于外表对另一个人形成的印象会产生深远的影响，即使这些印象是
not right. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不正确的。我是Shankar Vedantam。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。